le procès de patrick henry l'assassin
présumé du petit philippe bertrand s'est
ouvert ce matin dans le calme à 3 devant
la cour d'assises de l'aube
patrick henry est arrivé au palais de
justice dans un fourgon cellulaire une
heure avant l'ouverture de ce procès un
important service d'ordre est en place
dans tout le quartier où une quarantaine
de personnes seulement attendre on ne
sait quoi
à l'intérieur du palais le public n'est
composée que de 20 curieux la salle
étant presque entièrement occupée par la
presse jean-pierre à bout et jean pierre
berthet sont sur place pour tf1 et
appelle au calme et la sérénité ont été
entendus ce matin 3 n'a pas sombré dans
les excès la violence que l'on pouvait
craindre l'instant le plus émouvant est
elle arrivée à 8h45 de marie françoise
bertrand la mère du petit philippe que
vous voyez sur ces images accompagnées
par l'avocat de la famille m joannes en
étant suivi le général bertrand le père
de philippe au dernier moment et contre
l'avis de leurs proches
les parents de philippe ont tenu à
assister au procès quelques instants
plus tard les défenseurs de patrick
henry
tout d'abord m robert badinter suivi du
bâtonnier de chaumont m bocquillon
arrivent à leur tour à l'extérieur
derrière les grilles du palais de
justice une cinquantaine de troyens et
de troyenne assiste muet à l'ouverture
de ce procès
dès 8 heures les 27 jurés inscrit au
barreau de l'homme et des témoins
comment ça se présente et la salle
d'audience très petit et presque
exclusivement réservé aux journalistes
français et étrangers qui représentent
plus de 80 journaux radios et
télévisions patrick henry l'accusé est
arrivé à 8h05 dans un fourgon cellulaire
escorté de voitures de police et deux
motards pour faire face à toute
éventualité un très important service
d'ordre
deux escadrons de gardes mobiles une
section de crs et 40 policiers
contrôlaient tout le quartier
à 9h40 patrick henry que vous apercevez
de dos sur ces images entre dans la
salle d'audience
pas besoin de metteur en scène pour
diriger les acteurs de cette
extraordinaire dramatique judiciaire la
haine le chagrin et la peur ont déjà
marqué les débats d'une gravité
exceptionnelle les parents du petit
garçon assassinés se sont finalement
décidés à venir
explications de m embre leurs avocats
monsieur même bertrand ne crois pas aux
prétendus rep au repentir de patrick
henry et ils ont décidé de venir le lui
dire en face
alors ils écoutent l'acte d'accusation
le regard fixé sur l'accusé ils revivent
leur calvaire quand il est question de
petit cadavre enroulé dans une
couverture et dissimulé sous un lit
patrick henry écoute lui aussi les yeux
baissés
on a beau le regarder sous tous les
angles il n'a rien décidément en
apparence du truand du tueur habitué des
cours d'assises costume trois pièces
très strictes cheveux blonds roux bien
peignés allure propres est un jeune
homme bien comme il faut serait on tenté
de dire en le croisant dans la rue sans
savoir
cette impression de normalité se
confirme quand il répond avec précision
sans aucun effet particulier aux
questions du président sagols devant lui
son avocat maître robert badinter il ne
fait aucun mystère de l'orientation
qu'il entend donner à sa défense
s'adressant aux jurés il y a les faits
il y à la personnalité de patrick henry
mais il ya aussi la question de fond à
laquelle vous devrez répondre pour ou
contre la peine de mort seul
en définitive les neuf jurés sont
énigmatiques mais n'est ce pas la
fonction qu'ils exigent
on sait simplement qu'il y a trois
femmes sans profession un agriculteur un
mécanicien
un électricien un magasinier un
commerçant et un directeur d'école
cet après midi ce sont des témoins sur
la personnalité de patrick henry qui
vont continuer à déposer le vendeur